and as you can see the chancellor richie
sooner joins us in the studio lovely to
see you this morning chancellor a busy
day for you yesterday and a number of
kind of very eye-catching policy
announcements particularly those
targeted at the bottom end but can we
just start with with the windfall tax
why the u-turn it certainly felt for for
some time that the treasury was
resisting this tax on oil and gas
companies
well i've always approached this as a
pragmatist my view is
we wanted to find a way that we could
tax these profits fairly which i think
is the right thing to do given the
circumstances of a war leading to very
high prices which are leading to
excessive profits but i wanted to do
that in a way which would continue to
incentivize investment and that's why
we've taken the time to get this right
and our version of this contains a very
generous incentive for businesses to
continue investing so that the more
investment they make the less tax they
pay and that's good for us it's good for
the economy that's good for british jobs
and it's good for our energy security
and that was a balance that we wanted to
get right so and that's what we
announced yesterday so how much in total
is this this all going to cost i mean
the figure put out by the treasury
started at 15 billion yesterday and was
then revised upwards to 21 billion no
the what we announced yesterday was 15
billion pounds of new support to help
people with the cost of living but six
billion then from the spring statement
from from the yes
i've not mentioned that figure i've very
specifically said what we announced
yesterday was 15 billion pounds worth of
support to help with the cost of living
with the most vulnerable households
which is a third of all households in
the uk are receiving help worth around 1
200 pounds but there's also support
available for everyone because we
promised we would stand by the british
people at this time and yesterday that's
what we did why now why not in the in
the spring statement i mean this idea of
a windfall tax has been kicking around
for for several months now well on on
the
the levy that we're putting on energy
companies as i said we wanted to take
the time to get that right so we could
also incentivize investment that is a
very different feature of how we're
doing this it's an important one and i
think it was important to take the time
to get that right but why now that's a
perfectly fair question i've always been
consistent and i've said since the
spring earlier in the spring that i was
prepared to do more and we would do more
but it was right to wait until we had
some more certainty about what would
happen to energy bills in the autumn
they're the biggest driver of the
increase in responsibility so if i could
they're the biggest driver of the cost
of living and it wasn't until this week
we heard from offgem who are the
regulator that sets those prices that we
now have a bit of clarity about that and
that meant i could size the support
appropriately yeah okay but the office
for budget responsibility pointed out in
the spring statement that the energy cap
could be rising by october to two
thousand eight hundred percent and the
information was already there no and and
the key thing is could uh and the the
office budget responsibility are not the
independent regulator that set the
energy price cap they're one of many
people who have a view on what it might
have been and the reality is the price
cap is set over a period from february
through to the summer so it simply isn't
the case that anyone had any good idea
about what it was at the beginning of
that period now we're further through we
do have a good idea we heard from the
regulator on tuesday i think it was uh
from off gem and we've acted i think
quite quickly in making sure that we can
provide support and give people
reassurance do you understand why
several of your colleagues and quite
high profile colleagues have suggested
that this is not a particularly
conservative announcement i mean you had
uh the head of the ifs quoted in the
times today saying that gordon brown
would be pleased with this particular
announcement given how we distributed
this today well i think when we're
dealing as a country with the type of
challenge that we now face with
inflation running where it is
i think the right response from a
compassionate conservative government is
as we have done by the past two years to
stand by people at a time of need and
that's why it's particularly important
that those most vulnerable get the most
support that's what you saw yesterday
but we also recognize that with bills
going up on this scale everyone is going
to feel the pinch and that's why we
wanted to make sure that there was
support available for everyone on a more
universal basis 400 pounds this autumn
on top of the 150 pounds council tax
rebate that has already gone in place
you know i think that's the right
balance but we've also done it in a
responsible way by helping to raise
money to pay for some of the measures of
course there's not being a budget we
didn't have the kind of the detail that
you might might usually get the office
for budget responsibility hasn't been
able to go through it so some specific
questions on on costing that you
presumably have done what effect does
the treasury think that this will have
on on inflation well as you said that
will be a matter for the office for
budget responsibility you must have done
your own when they do their formal
independent uh review and analysis i
think it's
our estimate my view is that it will
have a minimal impact on inflation and
that's for two what do you mean by
minimum one percentage point no
much much less than that minimal and the
reason for that is twofold one is that
because what we're doing is
very targeted at those most in need
and and secondly because we're also
raising money to help pay for it the
combination of those two things is the
responsible approach because even though
we are as you said supporting the
economy we want to make sure that we
don't make the inflation situation worse
and you know doing what some people
might say is you should just spend even
more or borrow even more i think that
would be irresponsible because that
would risk driving up inflation interest
rates and people's mortgages and that's
not something that i think we should be
doing sure but you you say that it's
targeted at most in need i do wonder
then why you haven't means tested the
400 pounds payment i'm going to be
slightly churlish i will not be the only
person who makes this point this morning
it was just a week ago that you and your
wife appeared in the sunday times rich
list you know fast forward to yesterday
and the most eye-catching policy that
you announced yesterday to you know to
target those who are most in need ends
up with both you and i ending up 400
pounds better off i mean we don't need
the money well so in terms of you look
at the overall package that we announced
yesterday three quarters of the funding
is going to the most vulnerable
households and pensioners right but
let's talk about the question
the scale of the four hundred people so
you're going to hear what even i'm going
to receive yes and you and i and you and
i don't need it but actually lots and
lots and lots of people why are we
receiving anything because
when you're trying to help people on
that scale when you need to get help to
tens of millions of people right
actually you've got a choice how best
can you deliver that and the reality is
when you're talking about that number of
people there really aren't many ways to
do it and we wanted to make sure that
this was as universal as possible we had
another alternative of doing that which
was a council tax rebate which is where
you can try and
exclude people right at the top in very
large houses but you know what we tried
that and we tried to do it with a
discretionary fund and it's worked
reasonably well but there are lots of
cases of people who will say hang on i
happen to live in this you know
expensive looking house or in a high
council tax ban house but i need help
too so actually this being universal
means that we avoid all of those
problems and really do get help to
everyone who needs it and you like me if
i'm sure like me you can also give that
money to charity if you don't need it
and that's that's great which which is
great but you know it strikes me that
rich people didn't get rich by handing
back free money that they received from
the government it's good for you that
you're going to donate it to charity a
wager most people who receive it won't
oh well i'm done most people i'm sure
you will and set an example but i said
if i think it's incumbent on someone to
say well here's the alternative
how would you else how else would you
get the support to those on middle
incomes who are working hard who do feel
they need support and i hear a lot from
them every week just because they're not
on benefits or they don't they're not
pensioners they still actually think
this is tough for me it's a 1 200 pound
increase in my energy bill it's right
that the government's on my side and i
do want to be on the side of those
people if there's another way to help
those people whilst figuring out the the
smaller minority of very wealthy people
who don't need it i would be very open
to it but actually when you're trying to
deliver support in my job practically to
tens of millions of people you've got to
just figure out how best to do that and
i do think this is the right way one of
the the electricity generators a lot of
people were suspecting that they may
well have been included in the windfall
tax they weren't
just trying to understand why well what
we said if you look at the language i
use and i was very precise about this
it is the case that there are we think
extraordinary profits being made in that
sector as a result again of elevated gas
prices because of the war in ukraine but
what we want to do and we are going to
do urgently is understand the scale of
those profits and then decide on the
appropriate next step so they're going
to have to cough up at some point just
not yet well we do have plans in place
to reform that market so other countries
in europe like france italy spain
portugal greece have all taken steps to
reform that market to correct that now
we have a plan to do the same thing so
what we're sitting down now is figuring
out well how quickly can that be put in
place and in the interim what would be
the appropriate steps just one final
question on what we had yesterday in
terms of um pensions and benefits if
inflation gets to 10 or or even higher
what is your estimate of how much more
we will have it be having to pay in
terms of pensions and benefits ed conway
did a little bit of a kind of a back of
a [ __ ] packet calculation yesterday and
he came up with a figure we can bring it
up here of around about 25 billion
pounds worth of additional expenditure
is he in the ballpark oh well actually
you talked about the office for budget
responsibility who are our independent
forecaster in the spring statement they
have already included the impact of
pensions and benefits next year going up
by a relatively
large amount relative to inflation is
that is that bigger i mean it's not
bigger i precisely recognize but
actually the numbers that we have do
assume that that happens and that
actually should give people reassurance
that next year actually their pensions
and benefits will be rising well in
excess of what inflation is currently
forecasted to be the support we've
provided yesterday will help bridge
people from here to there and i think it
will be very significant it's meaningful
and will make an enormous difference
particularly to those most vulnerable in
our society i bet you thought you were
going to get through an interview
without talking about parties and dining
strip i'm afraid we have to um one thing
that that has been striking a lot of
people myself included
in terms of the prime minister's defense
is that he felt that it was necessary
for him to attend leaving parties for
members of his staff
why
well i think the prime minister has has
rightly
explained his actions and taken full
responsibility for everything that
happened in downing street he's
apologized profusely for it and i think
most importantly as well has as he said
just the other day learnt the lessons
from what's happened and made changes
and i see that because it's also a
building where i work and he's made
significant changes to how downing
street runs which is the right thing to
do and he has and he's actually
committed and he's more determined about
delivering for the british people
his defense has been that he felt that
it was part of the job to pitch up and
and say goodbye to people who are
leaving leaving
i just wonder what planet the prime
minister is on in the middle of a viral
pandemic no one else was doing that i
spent a year siloed away from the people
who work on this very program i saw a
security guard i saw a floor manager and
i saw the lady who cleans our studio for
about the best part of a year that was
it and i'm not running the country the
prime minister went from meeting of
cobra meeting of cabinet meeting with
advisors partying the flat a leaving do
i mean this was at a time of a viral
pandemic why was the prime minister
putting himself in harm's way in that
fashion well
these these matters have all been now
fully looked at by both sue grey
independently and also by the police
they've reached all their conclusions
the prime minister's apologized and made
a statement and importantly now made
changes in how downing street runs i do
think that's the right approach and he
has my full support in carrying on now
and delivering for the british people
richie good to have you in the studio
thanks for joining us